are search engines no longer needed the
media believes that new chat Bots will
replace search engines filled with
adverts let's take a look at the example
of GPT this AI can provide you with the
definitions of terms that you are
interested in chat GPT can write decent
essays so it has even been banned in New
York school recently this AI actually
sat an MBA exam at one of the best
business schools in the world a chat
spot is able to write not just an essay
but also many other interesting things
actually let's see if AI can make a
better Drake song than Drake I don't
want no kidney beans no black beans no
Pinto I want my chili to be packed with
flavored not just for filler furthermore
you can chat with artificial
intelligence chat gpt's database is
limited to data from 2021 for now but
what might happen if it was connected to
the internet perhaps in pursuit of
leadership Google will finally present
its Lambda chatbots to the general
public whose engineer said that Lambda
has its own Consciousness and mind
what do you think how else will AI
surprise us this year